In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 12 on which we commemorate our venerable father
Peter the Athanite.
This other angel of the desert was formerly a soldier in the fifth scola of the Byzantine
army.
During a campaign against the Arabs, he was captured in Syria and shut up in the public
prison of Samara, their capital, north of Baghdad.
The sheer misery of this bitter incarceration brought him to his senses, and he remembered
that he had formerly made a vow to become a monk.
But forgetting his promise, he had become a soldier.
Repenting he implored Saint Nicholas, the mighty intercessor for the despairing, to come
to his aid, promising to become a monk in Rome if he regained his liberty.
After he had spent a week in prayer and fasting, Saint Nicholas appeared to him twice
to encourage him to persevere in prayer, and thus seize hold of divine mercy.
On the third occasion, he appeared to him in the company of Saint Simeon, the God receiver,
and told the prisoner that in uniting their prayers, they had obtained his freedom.
The elderly Simeon, who was dressed as a high priest of the old covenant, touched Peter's
chains with his stick, and they immediately fell apart, like wax under the heat of fire.
They took him out of the prison, and Saint Simeon disappeared.
Saint Nicholas then accompanied him to Rome.
During the Sunday liturgy in Saint Peter's Basilica, the Pope, who had been instructed by
Saint Nicholas in a dream, distinguished the elect of God among the crowd, made him approach
and tonsored him a monk, giving him the name of the chief of the apostles.
He spent some time in Rome being instructed in the principles of the monastic life, and
then embarked on a ship to return to the east.
During the voyage, the blessed one ate only an ounce of bread a day, and drank seawater,
making himself much admired by the sailors, who showed him great respect.
After some days at sea, they put in to a port to stock up on provisions, where Saint Peter
healed a family, sick with mortal fever by his prayer.
One night, as the ship was anchored in calm waters, he saw the mother of God appear to him
in glory, with Saint Nicholas at her side begging her to guide his protege to a suitable place,
where he might live a God-pleasing life.
Be all holy, replied, He will not find rest, except on the mountain of Athos, situated
at the confines of east and west, that my son and my God has given me, so that those who retire
from the confusion of the world and its anxieties may serve God there, free from all distractions.
It will henceforth be called the Holy Mountain, and my garden, and one day it will be filled
with monks.
For those who endure temptation and affliction with patience there, glorifying the name of
my son, I shall be their providence, their refuge in battle, their physician, and their comfort
in this world, and I shall take up their defense on the last day to obtain the forgiveness
of their sins.
The southern face of Athos soon came into view, and the ship suddenly came to a standstill,
in spite of the favorable winds.
When he was told the name of the mountain, the Saint revealed to his companions that he
would have to leave them and settle there.
With tears in their eyes they left him on the shore, and when Peter made the sign of the
cross three times, the ship was able to depart, leaving him alone in this deserted place,
with its steep cliff.
Peter climbed up the slope with great difficulty, and finally came to a flat open space, where
he found a dark cave surrounded by thick vegetation which was a refuge for reptiles and the layer
for demons.
He settled there nevertheless, placing all his trust in God.
On the second day the devil, unable to bear the incense of his continual prayer, sent a
troop of his demons against him, who tried to terrify him with noises, cries, flying arrows
and jets of water.
The Saint, ready to offer himself as a martyr, remained unyielding, and as soon as he invoked
the name of the Mother of God, the demonic apparitions vanished.
Fifty days later, the spirits of darkness mobilized all the reptiles and wild animals on
the Holy Mountain against him, but Christ's soldier repulsed them by making the sign of
the cross and invoking the Lord.
Far from terrifying him, these attacks confirmed his Holy Resolution, and day by day he progressed
in virtue.
Three from every care and distraction he was able to gather the powers of his soul in
his heart, and to present his intellect, death and dumb before God, in a very pure prayer.
His heart became another heaven, in which the rays of divine grace shown forth, even as
time passed, transforming his body.
It's such progress infuriated the devil, who would not confess to being defeated.
After a year he appeared to the hermit in the guise of one of his younger servants, who
tried to persuade him to leave the Holy Mountain, reminding him of his distraught parents and
promising to find him just as quiet a monastery in the city.
The saint was deeply moved, but replied, know that it was no angel or human being who brought
me here, but God alone, and the all-holy Mother of God.
Without their command, I cannot leave this place.
As soon as he heard the name of the Mother of God, the demon disappeared.
Seven years later, he appeared to him once more, transformed this time into an angel of light,
an unsheathed sword in his hand.
He stood before the entrance of the cave and proclaimed to the saint that he had brought him
a crown of glory, for he had surpassed the prophets and the saints by his strivings and prayer.
He added that he must now return to live in the world, so that a great number of people
might be edified and saved.
Saint Peter replied, who am I, dog that I am, that an angel should appear to me?
And once more, the demons beat a retreat, as though burned by the humility of the man of God.
The following night, the Mother of God appeared to him, together with Saint Nicholas and said
to him, from now on, have no fear.
And she promised him that every forty days an angel would come to bring him heavenly manna
for food, having extinguished the sources of the passions by his endeavors, and having
been clothed in the cloak of impassibility by grace, the saint spent fifty-three years in
Hisekiya.
He endured without difficulty the rigors of the climate and of solitude, for divine contemplation
served him as food, clothing and consolation.
When God decided to reveal his angelic manner of life to the world, a hunter, who had ventured
into the thick forest in the south of Athos in search of a large deer, was led to the saint's
cave.
Being an old man appeared before him, clothed only in a loincloth made of leaves, with
a long beard and hair white as snow reaching to his belt.
He was troubled and seized with great fear.
But Saint Peter reassured him, and gently told him about his life, his struggles, and the
grace God had bestowed on him.
Marveling, the hunter gave thanks to God for having considered him worthy of such a
meeting and asked to live with the saint.
Peter however ordered him to return home, to give his possessions away to the poor, and
afterwards to practice the ascetic life for a year, to say farewell to his family, and then
to return and join him.
The following year the hunter returned to Athos, accompanied by two monks, and his own brother,
who was possessed by a demon.
But they found that the blessed saint was already sleeping, the sleep of eternal life.
His hands crossed on his breast, and his eyes closed.
As soon as his brother touched the body, he was shaken by violent convulsions, and the demon
came out of him, cursing Peter, who for more than fifty years had not ceased to make a mockery
of him.
They placed the saint's body in their boat, and sailed towards the north.
Yet as soon as they arrived opposite the monastery of Clement, for since the time that Saint Peter
had come to live on Athos, the number of monks on the Holy Mountain had grown and monasteries
had been founded, the boat abruptly came to a halt.
The monks of the monastery came to their aid, and in spite of their desire to keep its
secret, they were obliged to tell the abbot what the treasure was that they were carrying.
The Holy Relic was transferred to the church, where miracles immediately began to be wrought.
Bringing not only the monks from the whole peninsula, but also the crowd of people from
the surrounding areas.
It was later placed in the church of the mother of God.
The hunter and his brother returned home, and the two monks, pretending they wished to spend
the rest of their lives under the saint's protection, settled near the relic.
However, some days later they stole it under cover of night, and fled away by boat.
When they came near the village of Fotokomi in Thrace, the people came out in force
to meet them, wishing to venerate the saint who had just delivered them from the demons who
lived in their wells.
They opened a sack that contained the relic, and immediately it gave forth a divinely fragrant
bomb, a numerous healings took place.
These miracles drew such a crowd that the bishop of the region, having been told, came
with all his clergy and made the two monks surrender their precious booty.
In spite of the vain attempts of the devil, who sent a man to burn and destroy it, the
Holy Relic was placed in the church of the diocese, where it became a source of miracles
and consolation for the inhabitants of the region.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.